how many people do you see in this
picture
see i see one
two
three
four five
six people in this picture so i'm gonna
choose six this is fun let me keep going
how many wheels do i see in the picture
one two three four five six seven eight
i want to scroll down and make sure i
don't miss these over here 9 10 11 12 13
14 15 16 wheels
there's 16 wheels these four cars have
16 wheels
so 16 wheels let's keep going
how many people are in the boat i see
one two and three there's the guy rowing
it there's i guess the mother and then
there's the baby there's three people in
this boat
three people in the boat
this is too much fun how many faces do i
see one two three four five six seven
eight nine ten
faces
keep going
how many bottles do i see
one two three four bottles
and we're done